well hello to the lovely ladies of
allure real estate you guys made
a show i will say
i mean
are you surprised
no and i think we we got to get into all
of it though i
i will be on my best behavior because hr
is in the room isn't she
here
joanna let's start there how do you feel
about that reputation and everybody
feeling a certain type of way about you
being in their business and thinking
you're sherelle's shadow and now
joanna's in everyone's business so i
just named her hr unpack that for me
honestly it's funny uh because i'm
really not hr it just that's kind of the
nickname that they decided that they
were going to give me for whatever
reason and i'm going to live up to it so
it's breathing
but it's it's just i think the way the
office is set up and how the
relationship that sherell and i have uh
in terms of my role and it's just kind
of developed into probably a little bit
more and i think some of the ladies may
feel a type of way about it well they
definitely feel a type of way hr is not
on this call so we can be open
[Applause]
i want to start there um in colony i'll
direct this to you because the season
ends with cherelle
making joanna kind of officially
her second in command um after you had
you know been like i'm gonna shoot my
shot where are you at with
that and did it make you reconsider
rina's offer of maybe allure is not the
place to be oh
well you know i'm big on loyalty
huge on loyalty and even though sherelle
didn't choose me
um i think she'll soon see that she made
the wrong decision so
she's probably going to be regretting
her decision very soon okay
um shoot your shot and shots fired there
um
hey
maybe six months from now i can bring
you back under a little but right now
it's it's not it
okay
alexis something else that gave us that
drama
end of the season you are let go from
allure real estate the door's not really
open but it's not bolted i would say
where are we at right now
because you're in the you're physically
in the office it's definitely still
family um they're always going to be
a big part of my heart a big part of you
know who
who i am today i definitely would like
to come back but we'll just have to see
what happens
all right shirelle you hear the lady is
it
where are you at on this
alexis no well all the ladies know i
don't sugarcoat anything if they're not
performing and they're not meeting the
standards the lower standards
then
you have to go you get cut
i love you from afar i just have to take
my hands off of you until you can come
back if if you're willing to show that
you can change and produce then
i'll think about bringing you back okay
it doesn't sound like the needles moved
a lot but we let her in the building
today and we all respect that carla the
season ends with your office buddy
alexis
being shown the door yes and i feel like
that was maybe a heart and butthole
moment for you seeing your friend
it was it was i felt bad i felt bad i
wish i could do something for it but did
that make you be like i'm going to kick
it into
gear 10 000 now for sure i went
head first i was like you know what this
is my chance this is my warning
to knock it up a bunch so that's what i
did i've been really toying with the
idea of starting my own brokerage and
going out on my own yeah we left
the season with you
maybe going out on your own maybe not
can you let me know where did it land
have you opened your own brokerage i
mean who knows you're gonna have to stay
tuned i mean that big leather chair
looked good on you it did didn't it
it really looked like i could take over
the world in that chair
if you were a broker arena or the broker
because you are a broker what would your
ideal commission split be
ooh the ideal commission split would be
one that
i set
up front with my agents
and that we maintain throughout the
business so i think that's the important
thing for me is that i have this
agreement with my agent and that they
can rely on me to keep that that
agreement unless i come and talk to them
and there's a reason like if it's based
on their performance or something okay
you and sherrell different povs
we got very different points with you
yes
if you want to leave
i'm not begging no one to stay
wow shirelle congratulations on is it
baby serenity hanging in there well
congratulations on that it is not hard
to figure out that you have launched a
miami office of allure so what does that
mean for the future of the tampa office
where did you decide to
to land are you in between cities i'm a
businesswoman when i was in the military
we relocate but we still have you know
have our
place of duty our main place of duty our
lord realty is my main place of duty
this is my baby so
i just know how to multitask that's why
you delegate delegation is the key
and we have joanna sitting right next to
you for all those delegated tasks and
sophie we left off the season with you
thinking you were gonna get into the uh
your broker license where are you at
with that did you decide to pursue it
actively working on it okay and where
are you at about
staying at a lure going somewhere else
because you were like show me all the
possibilities
listen i am i'm an open-minded woman
okay
so as far as where i'm going i mean you
just gotta stay tuned because
i change like the wind i'm just
don't check me cause you
you are part of what is sure to be a
much talked about moment this season and
alexis too i mean you're all in the
you're all in the scene but it's really
between the two of you the miami dinner
you held yourself back from i think
doing what you wanted to do which was
maybe lunge across that table
what what held you back and did you have
in the back of your mind as you're
making this show that you you all
collectively wanted to represent
yourselves and your community a certain
type of way while literally the world is
watching
what held me back is that um because i
still have like
love for alexis but i don't want to like
get into a physical altercation with her
because
that's how she expresses herself
and so with me being a little older than
her i just know how to compose myself a
little
so yeah
like i don't i don't want to get into a
situation that i can't come back from
but it could have easily went there she
had to think about her job at a lure
i was gonna say you laid down the law
shirelle and then joanna actually i
think took an hr moment and pulled you
into the hallway to neil and said we are
not gonna do this
i'm happy to see that the nieces
resolved the issue those couple episodes
where you two were not
on the same page
i was not i don't know i hated it i
don't like fighting with aunt and it's
my girl but you know i had to let her
know girl that wasn't cool so
but i'm glad we resolved it i'm glad we
heard it
and i think friends can do that i think
that's a real friendship we're not going
to agree on everything so
it works i think what's important is
that we respect each other's decisions
and that's just that all right my last
question was the office actually set up
this way before you started making the
show or were they like this is how the
selling sunset office looks because you
guys have like the florida fied version
of the oppenheim group offices
that's what it sounds like
that's original
different story this is our own style
this is the black version style
i i think the allure officers are
prettier so we'll leave it at that
thank you brian
thank you guys congratulations it is a
show with a capital s
nice thank you
[Music]
you